there was one Bank
who didn't give a toss for their
customers they were told if a Armed
robber comes in don't matter if there's
customers there drop down behind the
counter they can't shoot for a
bulletproof screen what about the
customers customers got to take their
chances
have you guys met before we go back a
long way in the Eraser you know her high
security prisons in the 90s obviously I
I knew Razer when he was active you know
he was one of the old school armed
robbers that people like myself looked
up to
yeah I remember uh raya's um one of the
younger lads who was a bit of a handful
right here I remember hearing about you
long before I met you in the prison
system and um you know I first heard a
right as a an amazing fighter
um who had plenty of bottle and was uh
you know was an up-and-comer I mean a
lot of people were saying he's going to
be like the next uh big thing
in the crime world so yeah that was when
I first met Ray if I was any good at it
and I didn't keep getting cold yeah so
my parents were Irish immigrants and um
very very poor people we lived in
poverty in the 60s really
um when I tell my grandkids this they
kind of looked me and say you're ancient
greendo but to me I was born like 15
years after the second world war so all
the bomb sites around London and that
when we was growing up it was like it
was like Adventure playgrounds
everywhere when it my first actual
nickname was um was it was a fit I
bought a police they
took me off the street at the age of 14
when I was playing Trump me and my mate
and they beat and tortured Us in the
back of a van broke my finger snapped my
finger and made us admit to a load of
crimes that we hadn't committed
well it was like Fury
similar to Razer you know there was not
a lot of money to go around the worse
thing about it was the particular part
of it uh South London that I come from
was known as Bandit country when it was
right from where razor is right from
where I grew up and saw Woolwich right
about to Deptford and bowmancy and you
had all the Premier League armed robbers
in that area it was known as being
Bandit country
I fell into the ends of young sort of
gang culture and peer pressure because I
wasn't a tough kid and I say this and
I'm quite open and honest about this I
don't I wasn't this big hard tough kid
even though my history might suggest
otherwise through different things I've
done in life regrettably
but I had to learn that stuff and and
and and and the the upbringing and the
scars and becoming battle wild and
happened over time when I was a kid I
was [ __ ] scared of my own ghost I
suppose my first real
um crime that I set out to do was
um
was actually stealing a motorbike rolled
out to Stratton police station about
three in the morning
launched a brick through the police
station window and drove off so that was
my first actual crime real crime
I was getting into trouble much like
Razer from from Once I left school from
Once I was 16 17 and again uh very
similar experiences to raise at a place
at the time we had the what was called
the SPG which was the special Patrol
group there's a patrol our estate in a
van full of police
and they would you know they fit many
people up on our estate where else they
surround us up uh you know targeters
and um
yeah the progression into sort of like
how the crime happened for me quite
quickly when when we were 16 17 we used
to steal high-powered cars and
high-powered motorbikes and whatever
else we was like a bit of a Adrenaline
Junkies whatever whatever it was that
was noticed by some of the more
professional runners or whatever else
and we would steal cars or whatever and
they would give us a bit of money for
the cars and we would know what they're
being used for but we wouldn't you know
we
like they trusted us enough to know we
could Supply the views and it just made
sense to us to try and emulate and we
had the we was nicking the high-powered
cars at the time or whatever and well
you know what we can go and do a robbery
and we got a good chance of getting away
on a motorbike or a car and that's how
it was you know we we would uh use
high-powered motorbikes stolen
motorbikes stolen cars the thing is I I
started committing
um series on robberies at the age of 15.
and my first obviously I had no um
uh no experience of what to do but I'd
seen a lot of films and I've seen you
know locals who I knew who were at it
and um
so me until my pals planned this robbery
on a record shop
and it was just a nightmare from start
to finish we we ended up stealing
actually 10 pounds
and an arm full of LPS from the Record
Shop which was three pound Thirty each I
think and you would think that having
seen what you were able to steal at
three pound for a for an armed robbery
you know you'd lose sort of faith in it
want to do something else
but the other two yeah they they said oh
this is not worth it but me I had got
the buzz from doing it I've got the
adrenaline
that's that's the trouble with um armed
robbery evolving over the years is also
that the other side evolved as well and
when the other side evolved you've then
got to count what they do I'll give you
an example back in the 50s people used
to do robberies with a Kosh
they pick up the wages from the bank on
a Friday two geysers would be walking
back with the wages you pull up in a car
cost them on the head take the bag gone
so then when security guards come in
they um wore a crush out of it but they
didn't have a visor on it so security so
robbers instead of hit them on the end
would spray him in the ice with ammonia
or paint or whatever to temporarily
blind them so they started wearing
visors so what the rappers done then was
carried spray paint so they just spray
up the visor they couldn't see what was
going on let them in the body a few
times and run off with the box and
that's how everything that comes out
robbers have to find a counter for that
if you're a professional criminal you've
got to keep up to date on everything
that's happening and make sure that
you're able to counter it I'll give you
another example that we counted at one
stage a lot of the banks it was mainly
the Midland Bank uh started having what
they called a a safety lock between the
two doors so you'd have two doors into
the bank you'd have a foyer and then
you'd have two doors there but when you
came through those doors and those doors
closed it locked so you could only get
into that one
um you could get into that one but if
you try to get out they could lock it
from behind the counter yeah so what we
used to do was then carry a breeze Block
in a holdall and as you went in just
drop it down by the door in the center
hold the door open so we could Rob the
place and get out without them being
able to lock the doors but that's what
it's about uh professional crime you've
got to keep up with everything that's
going on and as they evolve you have to
evolve and that's what happens and you
know as well like we knew their policy
on handing over money on Union policy on
Banks and post offices as cruel and as
selfish as it sounds at the time I had
no fault for victims or no empathy or
nothing that's that's not the case today
may I add you know I have great remorse
I think anyone who's lived that life
does you know I wouldn't glamorize in
any shape or form but we knew when they
brought in for example the security
screens that boom shut up remember they
went up in a split second like that
you would always make sure before you
went in you would go in just after the
secure cover and had done their delivery
because you knew the safe would be open
because they're on a Time lap didn't
they and you would make sure that there
is at least a customer in the premises
because if there was a customer this
side of the counter their policy was
cooperate because they wouldn't want to
put the customer at risk will it yeah if
there was no customer in there and you
ran in that the screens would go
straight up or I know someone who
obviously I won't say he went in one and
and boom they and the whole place filled
with smoke it was like that was another
thing there but they wouldn't do that if
there was a customer in the bank would
they you know what I mean so we knew
their policy and they would um they
would comply that was the thing in some
senses it made them
uh seem to people like cars quite soft
targets we know we could be in and out
quick enough and we knew they would
comply except one but there was one Bank
um who didn't give a toss for their
customers and nobody would Rob them if
fair enough they got people to not Rob
them but they were told if a armed
robber comes in don't matter if there's
customers there drop down behind the
counter they can't shoot for a
bulletproof screen what about the
customers customers got to take their
chances and that was the policy of bank
they got less robberies than any other
person they still got people attempting
I mean I I've robbed about four of them
and got away
from tow with money and I had to
directly you had to directly threaten
the customers and I'm shouting over to
them if you don't come up I'm going to
put one in this geezer's leg and the
customers are all there [ __ ]
themselves and I'm going to because
they'd then be on the counter and I'm
counting the customers like as you can
say now I'm not going to show you I'm
just trying to get them up and in fact
my favorite Bank was the Midland Bank no
longer exists and they were called The
Listening bank and they certainly were
the listening I robbed some of their
branches four or five times and they
were always ready to hand over it was a
great Bank
and then when I got out of that I went
to jail and unfortunately they closed
them all down and it became the HSBC and
that's now my bank on their bank at HSBC
crazy unit
the biggest jobs are normally the ones
you've got away with right so
um I will say the most I've ever taken
out of a bank for example out of a
Midland Bank funny enough was 48 000
pound in cash that's the most you get
out of a bank but what you've got to
bear in mind is this
if people are robbing building societies
and they're just doing the tools on the
bank you're talking about five six
between five and say 11 Grand 12 Grand
which is a lovely bit of money if like
there's three of you doing it and you're
not working and that's your only income
that's a good bit of dough
what about Yuri what was your biggest
one well I mean obviously I wouldn't go
into detail I've had quite a few high
value because I know us at a smaller
period when I was younger where we
robbed a few Jewelers and different bits
of Bob's in in terms of monetary value
it would be you know one particular one
was probably close to half a million
pound but we didn't see that sort of
money and and and again another one
which I can talk about that I was
convicted of was a post office and I had
homes about 400 000 but it was most of
it was in stamps and tax disks and
because we took everything because back
then you these things were money well
money like you didn't have uh ampr
cameras or number plates now if I had a
stolen tax disc and I stamped it and you
put it in your car as far as I was
concerned you were
texting
I think so yeah I had a box falls about
three hundred thousand pounds worth of
taxes and when I did actually get
arrested for it they were more
interested in that than anything because
they knew obviously that was default in
the state and found stamps and all that
we had it doesn't really matter anyway
because as a professional equipment what
happens is we've added Thunderbirds
loads of times the minute you get nicked
they take everything yeah they take
every penny you've got they take all
your clothes in case they've used
robberies it's just it's just [ __ ]
tactics that the police use
when you have to spend years away from
your family and your children and your
grandchildren in the stinking places
weak classes prisons in this country
it's a disgrace you know and when you're
laying on a in a prison cell with two
broken ribs covered in your own vomit
with 12 years after serve it all becomes
a bit you think yourself it wasn't worth
it and it wasn't was it right you know
all the money we've had over the years
and it's never really been worth it not
for the time you're spend in jail mate
again like razor says in the face of any
of it
none of it was worth anything you can't
put a price on your time you know you
really can't you know you can't put a
price of your time you know I paid some
heavy prices emotionally physically and
spiritually you know you know that long
periods of prison especially high
security prisons I mean I know the the
median narrative whatever you all
believe they're all holiday camps all
playing PlayStation maybe they are in
some open prisons but like Razer I mean
we've served time together I've been in
some dungeons segregation units special
units what was your longest serve
13 years
what about you know the longest sentence
I've got was eight life sentences plus
eight years concurrent
and it all boiled down to one life
sentence in the end and I ended up
serving 12 years out of that
um the biggest another big set I've got
19 years in 1989 I've got 26 years he
got cut at 19.
I've done 11 out of that
I've done a seven I've done a four for
sawing the bells off a shotgun
it's just non-stop time in prison and
whilst I was in prison you know prison
changes you you turn into
an emotionless animal I've witnessed
murder in prison in prison I I've
witnessed not not actually didn't
actually witness the I've seen many
violences but I've actually witnessed
the door get opened in the morning woman
prison officer scream run away and the
one cell mates killed his just killed
his cellmate in the night because they
should never have been locked up
together in the first place but because
of overcrowding
failures in the mental health State and
whatever else where there's no they just
lock them up you know smash a window in
the town really should be in hospital
I've nowhere though no results lock them
up put them in prison lock them up with
someone put them in the same cell as
them like they're perfectly safe to be
around and witness that witness suicides
that's horrific you know I've witnessed
someone in a dispersal system who slit
his throat ear to ear very lucky to
survive do you remember him
yeah just horrific self-harm I've people
have cut their ears off and all sorts
like I think the worst the worst actual
incident that I've seen was in Albany
prison in 1989 and it was uh a guy from
Deptford you know him anyway but it was
a guy from depth and an argument with a
lifer in the kitchen and you could do
your own cooking yeah and uh what he
done was he the guy threatened him with
a potato peeler so my mate come first
the heat can seem like he's gone down to
the counting and bought three pound a
lot
for cooking took it back put it all in a
big pot
boiled it till it was bubbling and the
geyser was in the toilet and there's
only a half dollar in the toilet and he
went out the way up with a pot and
bumped straight over his head a boiling
hot fat while he was in the toilet but
what it was he came everyone knew it was
going to happen
and this guy was he was a Rastafarian
and he came out the toilet and the
scream was unbelievable it was like
chilling and we all piled up around the
toilet and he come out and it was smunk
coming out of him his dreadlocks were
falling out his skin was peeling he was
going pink and he fell down and hit his
head on the urinal and the screws come
running in to sort him one of the screws
turned him over and then vomited on him
when he see the state of him but it was
just a horrific thing and you know he
got shipped there and he went to the
hospital and he just managed to survive
and the guy who've done it never got
nicked
um but there was a smell in that Wing
every time you come off exercise for the
next three or four weeks you could smell
burning flesh when you came out of the
wing despite the fact they had to have a
specialist cleaner in to clean all the
flesh that was on the floor
when and why did you decide to give up
the life the crime life
well for me it was quite um
I would say it was easy I was in
whitemore prison in 2001. and um I'll
come back from tea that night and I'd
rather make mine and looked and saw a
priest up at the end of the landing and
when you see a priest or a rabbi or a
vicar or a new man in prison
and they're not in the church it's
normally because someone's getting bad
news and sure enough uh he told me my 19
year old son Joseph had died outside in
mysterious circumstances
and I was obviously devastated it was
that that was the spur after all those
years I thought they wouldn't let me go
to my son's funeral they said I was too
dangerous to go and I had too many
criminal connections and they could
break me out or whatever I told them I'd
go down there on my own and come back on
me and which I would have done as a
matter of Honor but when they wouldn't
let me go to my son's funeral and my
son's daughter and I can't even Comfort
my family and I'm sitting in a prison
serving eight life sentence and walking
around giving it Charlie big spuds yeah
this is we've made it and I suddenly
realized this is not we haven't made
anything mate this is just a terrible
life that you've been living and for the
first time I stopped and looked at what
I'd been doing and I was [ __ ]
horrified
and obviously I was in a bad way because
my son had died and I decided to myself
that I was going to look around for some
sort of Rehabilitation
and the only place I could find that in
prison believe it or not was in a fairly
unique prison in buckinghamshire called
grendon which you have to volunteer for
and you work on therapy about yourself
psychotrauma all that sort of stuff for
years five years I was Ray done it as
well and you have to come to terms with
what you've done you have to realize the
victims you've left in your wake and the
thing is you can't unring a bell once
someone rings that Bell when you see
what you've done it's very odd then to
like because that's why we're saying
earlier on about you don't give a toss
about people when you're robbing you
dehumanize them you turn them into
cardboard cutouts so you're able to do
what you're doing because if you've
thought of every single person in a bank
of rob banks which 30 people in every
single person that bank was traumatized
impose on people by bursting in their
lives and waving firearms and threats
and doing our best to be horrible
bastards I mean you don't just walk away
from that that's you know those people
are suffering today when I never took
none of that into account course I think
I was a as I thought was [ __ ] Robin
not didn't I you know all them years I
thought was done a noble thing and I'm
doing a a a sort of honorable crime I
don't Rob old grannies of the Bingo
winnings or sexually abused children but
all the time I was missing the point I
was just another scumbag criminal with a
gun and once you realize that it's very
hard to go back and do what you've done
before
my dad died while I was uh well I was
about a year into that 13-year sentence
I wasn't they wouldn't let me go to the
funeral they said I was too much of a
security risk because I don't really
escape from prison you know prior to
that quite a violent escape and for me
you know I was just heading one way I
got I got arrested again in prison for a
violent assault against two prisoners
um I was in segregation
um in special care and control unit in
in long line in prison you know I was at
the end of the road two psychiatrists
come to interview me because uh the
different violent episodes in prison and
uh said one signature from me one
signature from him and you're off to
Broadmoor and that's the reality because
when you're in a high security prison
there's nowhere left to go you're not
going to be downgraded unless your
behavior improves if your behavior is
Big there's only one place they can send
you if they decide look we can't be
bothered with you going to the hospitals
in Eurasia and that's pretty much how it
was for me and it was a fantastic prison
officer and always mention a love hurt a
[ __ ] I believe she's dead now Cheryl
she was a Welsh prison officer she came
down to the segregation she took a
liking to me on the wing and she come
down to the segregation one day she said
if I get you back on the wing you
promise you'll behave yourself because
she knew what what their plan was for me
they was going to knock me off and send
me to one of the hospitals I said sure I
promise and so they offered me the
therapeutic group and like I say like
like Razer I say this eloquently because
it means so much for me conscience
becomes a fierce pursuer you know
there's so much in my life I can't and
never will talk about but when you've
lived that life and you really have
lived that life one day you wake up and
it's bang it's you especially when
you're in prison doing time there's a
reason they call it time because if you
versus your head
how does it feel to talk about it now
and kind of looking back at it all is it
regret do you feel
what is that
for me definitely
definitely because I have remorse I uh
do have remorse remorse for victims you
know when you've looked someone in the
eye down the end of a gun you mean the
act of armed robbery
that image sort of
it's like burned into your conscience
you know I've seen it yeah and I've also
had a victim statement read out in cult
against me for a robbery that I
committed and the particular person
wasn't able to go back to work
no less selfish I had no right to do
that and that's why today you know I do
so much I go above and beyond because it
feels right you know I do a lot for
victim Charities and things like that I
give freely in my time I contribute I
donate I build these things not for
praise or or I don't even tell people
why I do I do it because it feels right
and I feel like I owe society that you
know my past has become my greatest
essay because what archers are doing now
like a good selfies use it to good put
into good use you know in in terms of
Rehabilitation reform carrying a message
you know all that stuff it's it's become
very much an asset to me
if I had my chance to live my life over
again I wouldn't do none of it seriously
I wouldn't it was never worth it for me
so you finish a prison sentence you get
out you think what am I good for nothing
what did I learn in prison more crime
let's commit more crime and then you're
on this spiral this Merry-Go-Round like
all through your life and then
eventually when you step off it and
realize what the real world is like it's
a complete shock as what he says you
know you can use your past and I do you
know I use it same as Ray I talk to
students or going to schools and I work
for a prisoners newspaper but and your
past is there and it becomes sort of
part of you but I don't like to dwell on
it I don't I honestly don't like talking
about it
um and that might sound funny because
I've spoken I've made a living out of
bleeding speaking about it but uh there
comes a time when you think to yourself
now you know I've been through all this
so many times and it becomes you start
getting depressed when you think about
it again
I asked myself this on this question
could I go out and commit an armed
robbery now I don't think I could no me
neither I honestly don't believe I could
I don't have it in me and when I look
back at the damaged frightened young man
I was when I was that way I actually
feel quite sad I wish I could sit myself
down and have a word with myself because
I'm so far removed from who I once was
that I don't believe I've got it in me
today and even at that time I know this
is going to sound strange to anybody
watching this I don't believe I had it
in me then
I don't believe I had it in me then I
was just operating
factors against my control I felt like I
was out of control I had no choice I was
impulsive for I just done things and
even afterwards I'd think why did I go
there and
I don't think I could do it today no I
couldn't
I've taken an assistant Governor hostage
in a maximum security so everywhere I go
I've got loads of prison offices around
because they think I'm going to take
another one right about six or ten man
unlock ten man unlocked there you go